let's talk about what's happening in
Sudan rival forces remain locked in a
power struggle despite international
calls for a ceasefire
for control of the country between
Sudan's Army and a paramilitary unit
known as the rapid support forces the
rsf led by men who used to be allies
hundreds of people have been killed and
hundreds have been injured
there's fighting in different parts of
Sudan but its heaviest in the capital
Khartoum there have been attempts at a
ceasefire but they haven't lost it there
have been air attacks and shelling
the airport has been severely damaged
there's no running water or electricity
supplies of food are running low
this ridiculous battle that has
civilians caught in metal we have
nothing to do with this so what's behind
the fighting well people in Sudan have
been struggling to set up a democracy
after decades under one man rule
[Music]
Omar al-Bashir came to power in a
military coup in the late 1980s became
president and stayed for 30 years until
people rose up and demanded that he
stepped down
then the Army took over people didn't
want them in charge either
so after pressure from protesters the
Army agreed to share power with
different political groups in a
transitional government the idea was
that it would oversee a transition to a
democratic system
years later the Army kicked out the
Prime Minister and seized power again
the people in Sudan seemed to be trapped
in this limbo and they're going round
and round and the circle that involves
the same people you know with no clear
path or trajectory on how they can
actually start to plan for a
transitioning there have been ongoing
talks to make that transition happen
between the military and political
groups representing that pro-democracy
movement but a major reason the process
is being held up is because of an
underlying rivalry between the Army and
the rapid support forces that have
become like a second Army and many
people see this as a personal rivalry
between the Army's leader General Abdul
fatah al-brahan who is effectively the
leader of the country and the leader of
the rsf general Muhammad hamdan dagalu
widely known as hemeti the thing is for
years both men were on the same side and
had been since the war in Darfur
hametti led a militia at the time widely
known as the janjaweed and they were
used by albashir's Army to fight rebels
in the region of Darfur they were
created to protect the upper echelon of
the military and the senior commanders
they're accused of carrying out war
crimes there and al-Bashir actually got
charged with committing genocide
in 2013 the militia were rebranded as
the rapid support forces and worked with
the Army on different missions
then in 2019 hemeti and general alberhan
joined up to get rid of al-Bashir and
during the big pro-democracy protests
the rsf and the Army were accused of
killing more than 100 people
but since then the rsf has been acting a
lot more independently and they've grown
more powerful they were able to
establish fast and
fast in the country and outside the
country especially in the gold trade two
main actors the Army and the rapid
support forces were able to collude you
know now successfully for about four
years uh to stay in power themselves but
there was always that core tension
um about who was the top dog between
them so that brings us to the fighting
right now as part of Sudan's transition
to democracy there have been talks about
integrating the rsf into the army but
they can't agree over the timeline the
Army proposed two years while the rsf
wanted it to be 10. the Army
um you know had been making a stand they
realized that the the rapid support
forces have been growing um the head
General hemeti has political Ambitions
himself and I think there was a sense
that if they did not somehow force uh
the rapid support forces to agree to
integrate and to and to go under them
that this force would keep growing and
and grow out of the control of the
formal military
it's unclear who started the fighting
but on April 15th both sides started
trading accusations that they had
attacked each other's bases in cartoon
then they fought to take control of the
presidential Palace the airport
and the state TV channel
[Music]
the Army has air power and they've been
hitting rsf bases in the capital many of
them in residential areas
the rsf don't have planes but they do
have anti-aircraft weapons and they have
about a hundred thousand men there have
been plenty of calls for the fighting to
stop from Sudan's neighbors the African
Union the U.N the EU the U.S and the UK
and there could be some leverage from
countries like Egypt which has been a
close Ally to the Sudanese Army and on
the other side the UAE which has ties to
the rsf but there's no sign that either
side wants to back down right now for a
lot of people it's this is It's a period
of confusion it's a period of
uncertainty
um about what's going to happen in the
next few minutes the next few hours the
next few days
and uh it's a spirit of war and they
have nowhere to turn to a lot of people
in Sudan are scared heartbroken and
frustrated their country keeps getting
derailed off that path towards democracy
it's a hope that seems even more distant
now
[Music]